this collaboration it fits perfectly
so I've been wanting to talk about the
oddity that is the 1996 made-for-tv
Doctor Who movie which was the screen
debut and for a long time only
appearance of Paul McGann as the eighth
doctor for a while I really been mean to
get around to this but it seemed like
this deserved a little bit more than
just the usual me or ranting at the
camera so I reached out to one of my
favorite youtubers when it comes to
Doctor Who material ladies and gentlemen
please welcome to Council of geeks
Stuart hardy also known as Stu bagful
hey what's up oh hey sorry I just um I
guess that assumed I was gonna be
working with with real world Stuart I'm
not sure that real world Stu exists
anymore
I don't seen him for ages getting quite
worried about him actually but still you
got me and I'm almost as good well I
don't really have the time to find
anybody else so you'll do what a welcome
so right off the bat kind of a big red
flag for me was was when the credits
started and they didn't kick in with the
iconic part of the Doctor Who theme you
know them instead they start it in the
middle of the theme you know the day did
it end which is I guess cuz it's more
generically heroic and then another red
flag comes along a few seconds later
with the words special guest star Eric
Roberts Oh we'll be getting to that no
need to dive into the pain right away so
it starts with this bit of voiceover
explaining how the master was executed
and the doctor is carrying his remains
in the TARDIS so I have a question has
anyone taking up the challenge of trying
to explain why it won the Daleks are
holding a trial at all and to why
they're doing it for the master of all
people
oh yeah there's tons of
explanations actually I got this bit in
an 8th doctor book a few comic strips
tangentially related to said bits a few
fan productions and about eight
paragraphs for the fanfiction that I
wrote when I was 12 that I never
bothered finishing how's that right any
of those canon did I um and sure the
movie have told us that you know instead
of just throwing out this random premise
so that Doctor Who fans like us are
asking all these questions
well well yet but right by having a lazy
and hackneyed opening that's full of
holes
you can sell gullible and stupid fanboys
like me endless spin-off merchandise
that tries to explain away all the stuff
that we didn't think through Wow okay
that's actually kind of genius now that
I think about it you see sometimes the
long game works not the series one
episode the long game though well no not
that one now before we move on any
further I need to say this TARDIS
interior it just makes me so sad because
it's gorgeous and we never see it again
after this all's a bit on the nose
though isn't it how so you know tons of
clocks in the background he's reading
The Time Machine the record starts
skipping on the word time American
television production not known for
subtlety I'm a girl he is a time
traveler do you get it yet
hmm I wonder what this guy's deal is so
the doctor has to land the TARDIS and as
one would expect he does so on earth
because he's been racking up parking
violations everywhere else but instead
of his usual British stomping grounds he
ends up in LA in the 90s and is
naturally gunned down by a random street
gang there was a time I would have made
a second ammendment joke but they're
just never funny anymore so do we think
getting gunned down in a random alley is
the least dignified thing that ever
kicked off for a generation see I quite
like this in principle this is a bit
more of a realistic and relatable cause
of death than the other ones where he's
either contracted radiation poisoning
absorbed the time vortex or been
sentenced to death by the Time Lords
people die like this every day
one's not some huge dramatic event that
requires fall specials were that
build-up and sad looks
no he's gunned down in an alley it's
short and blunt and it comes out of
nowhere okay maybe but does he not check
the scanner to see who's outside before
he steps out anymore dyay
okay you got me that I think we can skip
past the character introductions of Lee
& Grace cuz three the crap or weird and
not very interesting in either case so
the master apparently now a combination
of one of those liquid metal terminators
and a snake breaks out and takes over
another guy's body and gets weird scary
eyes okay now I get that the master has
always been terrified of his own death
and the show really made a point of
emphasizing that he goes to further
lengths than any other Time Lord in
terms of avoiding his ultimate fate but
this movie seems to have confused master
with devil because demonic possession
imagery all over the place it's not
totally unfounded with stuff from the
classic show though
but with stuff like keep her at rock and
they justified and fleshed it out a bit
more so it gives it more meaning here it
pretty much happens just because
someone's a week into the regeneration
itself the doctor has amnesia because
look I know they justify it in the story
by saying that it's tied to the
anaesthetic that he was given his
screwed up his regeneration somehow but
narrative Lee I don't really get why he
has amnesia I don't know what the plot
function of that is especially
considering how quickly he gets over it
is it just to make him extra clingy to
grace I suppose but I wouldn't count
that as a benefit who would you rather
he latch on to the generic skeezy
hospital administrator honestly I have
gone with a peppy morgue attendant he
was a bit more engaging but they would
still have to kiss right I can't imagine
it would have caused that much more of a
fan backlash than the kiss with grace
did yeah true
but really the highlight of the whole
amnesia thing is it gives us the doctor
as thunder and lightnings going on going
really having a hard time thinking him
anymore over the top moment in Doctor
Who
you got anything let me remind you of a
little decade called the 1980s which
gave us gems like resurrection of the
Daleks ah I can't stand the confusion in
my mind
oh I blame the cocaine
so anyway circling back to our nominal
companion grace look you're more plugged
into classic who you know sort of fandom
and culture than I am is there a
consensus among older fans about whether
she's good
bad anything Oh Ross classic who fanboys
never have a consensus on anything we
just tear chunks out of each other over
everything from death to the Daleks to
Mel to the sex doctors ridiculous codes
and even on grace there's two camps
there's the people who actually remember
who she is and the people who can't
remember her at all and hazard a guess
that she was a side character in that
one where he fought the giant talking
cactus monster or something you know for
my perch she's just very 90s you know
she's in appropriately snarky to an
excessive degree she's a little too cool
for school I gotta say this since when
would a heart surgeon know about things
like spacial transference across
dimensions you know just being
generically smart doesn't automatically
make you a font of all knowledge it's
not even like she's being the genero the
generic all-purpose science is cliche
it's just one more opportunity for her
to have a snarky line but you know she
likes Oprah that's that's the character
try you know as we're going through this
I'm realizing that a lot of the
weirdness about this whole thing
it feels like they came up with stuff
that they wanted to do that has a
mechanical plot function and then they
didn't bother to justify it with
character motivation or even really
logic so like they're going through the
story they decide they want Lee to get
the doctors artifacts after the seventh
doctor dies so they have him ham the
hospital to get them later
except there's that makes absolutely no
sense because Louie doesn't know that
he's got anything worth taking and if he
hangs around after he's dropped off this
total stranger who he doesn't know he
knows he's gonna be asked a ton of
questions that he doesn't have the
answers to they want the doctor to have
an easy way to recognize the master so
suddenly we get monster eyes and then
you know we get sunglasses to cover
those up they decide they want the heart
the eye of Harmony to be something that
the doctor can open but the master can't
but also other characters besides either
of them could open as well so that the
master can have somebody else do it for
him then we have the whole human thing
so it's decided human eyes can do it
which means the doctors have human which
means the master isn't and all this
stuff works mechanically in terms of
getting the whole thing moving forward
but it doesn't work on any other level
besides just strict mechanics well yeah
it looks incredibly lazy but right by
contriving this the doctors half human
bollocks is a lazy way of making the
story work and throwing a massive
spanner in the works of 33 years worth
of Canon that they're a bit by 1996 that
means we can start selling dom fanboys
this series of 73 novels that try and
make sense of anything that happened in
this era for the franchise see it may
look lazy and contrived but financially
it's actually the cleverest thing ever
if you think about it you know it's rare
that I encounter a person even more
cynical than I am I consider that the
highest compliment and so we get a
pretty standard race against time stop
the master climax thing it's functional
enough that I'm not sure it's worth
picking apart and so I have to ask do we
want to talk about Eric Roberts as the
master do we have to yeah kinda
okay then I understand where the need to
rework the master came from he started
out as a sci-fi interpretation of a 60s
Bond villain you know the costumed
swirly moustache and given the
action-heavy focus in the Third Doctor's
era the Venusian karate aikido whatever
the point is they came up with a
recurring villain who suited the format
and the time period getting into the
fourth doctor's era the focus switched
heavily to horror and he got the master
as this sort of rotting zombie like
thing who ends up stealing
form of mrs. father in the keeper of
trap gun and is finally seen being
possessed by cat people on a dying
planet where we see instances of crazy
eyes the TV movie takes the
body-snatching element and the crazy
eyes but it doesn't have an actor who
can pull off this role with anywhere
near as much dignity as Anthony Ainley
and combines that with other inspiration
from other movie villains that the
makers want him to be like because it
was 1996 and everyone wanted their movie
villain to either be Jack Nicholson's
Joker or The Terminator
so he just comes across as this deformed
mess of a character made by people who
had no idea what they wanted him to be
I'm sorry I just got hung up on the
phrase the dignity of Anthony Ainley
that's a bit like hearing that somebody
is not as polite as Ted Nugent what's
yourself geek boy you know it's more
than just they weren't sure what they
wanted him to be it's like he's a
completely different character with a
different mo in every single scene he's
in he's all possessed and devil grinning
at first then he shows up with the
sunglasses and the leather acting like
the t1000 pretending to not be a machine
then he's all snarly and threatening and
then he's suave and manipulating to the
same person that he was threatening just
minutes ago then he's flamboyant to the
point that the beard comment in time
crash feels like a continuity fix for
this movie it's like they had an entire
idea bored of villain possibilities from
the pitch meeting and never bothered to
whittle them down how can we not have to
think about him anymore it's making my
brain hurt okay
for all the complains to be made about
this thing let's be fair on a few points
firstly it looks really good not only
other production values solid and the
effects work well enough but it's shot
much better than classic who really ever
was I admire the spirit that went into
the TV movie if you look over the back
story it's clear the exact producer
Philip Segal had good intentions as he
was trying to get a US pilot of Doctor
Who off the ground for years and what is
stupid over-the-top and cheesy saw was a
large chunk of classic ooh and I enjoy
that in spite of its glaringly obvious
flaws and I enjoyed this too even if the
flaws are a bit more
egregious in this case and I suppose we
can always thank this for giving us Paul
McGann though it would be a while before
he'd really get to shine in the part
what's the white dog alright it
definitely uh you know this whole thing
this movie it's a deeply flawed oddity
but if you can restrain your inner
continuity hound I'd say it's worth it
for the visual presentation and McGann
and the part yeah it's a fair assessment
well thanks for turning up avatar Stuart
I think that'll just wait um wait where
didn't real world me go oh god he's got
you too
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]